sourceless you just won five thousand
dollars in cash
yeah congratulations but every second
you go without dying
you lose fifty dollars starting now go
go die
is every minute it was every second
every second you've already lost a
hundred bucks you're losing fifty
dollars you've lost five hundred dollars
holy moly holy moly indeed
are you sure this is the fastest way uh
i could get wood but you're down to 3
500 crown already
oh there he goes he's drowning
thirty-one come on come on come on come
on hopes and dreams
hey did i just actually win that or am i
in heaven you just won two thousand nine
hundred and fifty dollars
holy moly mackerel i love you hey i
can't you are currently on a
giant plot of grass two years ago when
we did team trees
every dollar someone donated we planted
a tree and today
every tree you plant before the end of
this video i'm gonna give you
a dollar oh my gosh lay a sapling real
quick
you just made a dollar three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven i'm
going for it i'm going for it
you want me to help you go for it go for
it go speed plan
chris if she wins enough money i can't
pay you i don't care
yeah let's go are you sure you shouldn't
do like one row at a time
you missed this block i will fill
everything in i'm gonna make sure hey i
can't
have fun try not to win too much money
oh i'll definitely try to
good luck let every block you fall
without dying i'll give you 500 bucks
but you can't see what's below you okay
this is so scary
the green one it'd be pretty hard to die
the red one it'd be pretty easy to die
oh my god that's really hard to choose
it depends on how risky you are and if
you die
you get nothing do i get an extra chance
for the bee shirt no but you get a
cool crisp high five hey so pick a block
just pick any block and stand on it you
know what i trust you mr beast i'm going
this one
all right so i'm going to break the
block below you okay uh-oh and if you
die you get nothing okay i understand
every block you fall you get 500 bucks
good luck
and boom oh
whoa oh he survived with three hearts oh
my lord
you fell 21 blocks which means you made
ten and a half
thousand dollars what are you serious
good job choosing this one this is
really amazing and it's gonna help us so
much mr beast
this next bit is insane human 56
look inside that chest there's an egg if
that egg hatches the chicken i'll give
you
ten thousand dollars in cash oh my god
if you look it up on the minecraft wiki
they say you have a one in eight chance
of that egg spawning a chicken so you
basically have a one in eight chance of
ten thousand dollars i believe in you oh
my gosh you got this
oh please be a chicken five two
throw the chicken come on meat chicken
make a chicken
chris yeah don't worry i got it okay
thank you
bye we love you i'm sorry
hey i can't howard oh my gosh it's like
a forest here
i've been busy you have planted 5485
trees how does that make you feel that's
amazing wow okay
the ozone layer probably loves you hey i
cat these are my three weird friends
i'm chandler and you can pick any one of
them to plant trees with you for the
next 10 minutes which one do you want
i'd like chris hey wow didn't even
consider me you didn't give me a reason
you're losing money get the planted
jaws unleashed welcome back hello jaws
competed in this video here and he lost
ten thousand dollars no joke they called
each other
but that's my name grab the pickaxe in
this chest
got it you are on a giant floating
island and there is one diamond block on
this island
carl do you have to pee always jaws if
you can find the diamond block before
carl pees and comes back you get ten
thousand dollars and no longer clowned
on by your friends oh kind of like
now bye go go go
carl's rushing to the bathroom he's
rushing for the diamond you're very cold
you're very cold oh very cold cold cold
wait hold up hold up no wait wait watch
out watch out there is lava on this map
i have to get to the bathroom okay
that's all okay
keep going oh oh there's some lava i'm
gonna take care of that
wait keep going that direction keep
going i'm going i'm going yeah
okay keep going straight more lava
hold on hold on i think i found him i
could smell him oh pet rock
so you hit the bottom of the map that's
good to know it's good to know let's see
if he can find the diamond
drink i'm done going to the bathroom
good good did you fly yeah
hey taylor am i hotter coats
oh oh that's good
he got it yes cut the cars pov you see
there
he's not there which means you just won
ten thousand dollars
i don't feel like a chandler anymore
let's go i still feel like a chandler
for this next challenge we have adrian
and we have thrill and there's a giant
column of diamonds below both of you
every single diamond block you break you
get one thousand dollars
but if you break more than adrian you
get nothing so go ahead and break that
first diamond block
you just made a grant hey it's rich okay
one more
he doubled his money you just made two
grand you know i think i think three's a
charm
three thousand dollars it's for a charm
i'm doing for
4 000 is the most money i've ever looked
at in my
life i can't risk that what do you hate
money
adrian we just wrapped up with thrill
how many blocks do you think thorell
broke
six okay so you think he broke six which
means what you're gonna go for
five that's a safe bet i think so break
one all right all right one thousand
dollars you going for a second one
yeah two okay two thousand i mean you
said you think you broke six seven duck
myself here
there's no harm in three three that's
your limit i think he went low so i'm
gonna stop here
you could stop whenever you want so go
for four hey
all right so you're sure you want to do
four blocks no
thorell broke four blocks and adrian
broke
five you actually were tied and then you
just decided to do another one
oh god no throw congratulations on
winning four grand
four thousand is the most money i've
ever had in my entire life thank you so
much i'm glad you're happy and adrian
this is so sad
hey i can't you are killing it with the
progress chris you're only supposed to
help for 10 minutes it's been like 20.
hey i don't tell him about the speed
boost i gave you for
uh two hours chris leave split do you
know why you have potion of blindness
and a pumpkin on your head
i'm not supposed to see stuff exactly
here's a sword
every cow you kill i'll give you a
hundred dollars but you only have one
minute
go go go time's going you should
probably kill cows now
300 go straight go straight yeah yeah
is it your strategy to ignore the baby
cows right now because they're harder to
hit dude i'm not editing skywalker oh
god
there's a whole pile of cows right here
there's a sword grab that sword help him
kill cows i'ma just keep putting cows
around him
kill all the cows
come on split jimmy i don't know it
feels like it's been longer than a
minute
69 he killed 69 calories you're right
something there stop it there that's a
funny number you just won six thousand
nine hundred dollars
yeah let's go oh oh that's a lot of
money
but you have three seconds to say what
you want uh subscribe to mr beast and go
to go buy merch
roxy which do you like better tnt or
anvils tnt
sap nap which do you like better anvils
good you didn't actually have a choice
tp whichever one of you dies last gets 5
000
in cash cash server start it up
oh my god you got this zapped up zap nap
is getting rained on by anvils i can't
move
he's getting rained on by tnt i can't
even see sapnaf anymore there's so many
anvils
you got this zapnap i love you my heart
is racing i'll give you that
help me you can't let sapnap win
sadness don't you make plenty of money
not enough wait
i'm stacking up who's gonna win look at
all the anvils
oh my god i'm sorry how are you not dead
because i'm a minecraft professional
yeah i'm a kind of half hp i have two
hearts
i have two hearts
rock zoo died congratulations sapnap you
just ripped
five thousand dollars out of rock zoo's
hands i feel really bad
this is lock-ins 205 and this is evan
hello lochen you are on a giant parkour
course
either you finish and win 10 grand or
you lose and evan gets 10 grand
oh wow lock in start when you're ready
oh my god go walking
oh he did evan give him bad advice you
should totally just like go down the
actual end is at the bottom
falcons you're actually doing pretty
good lockets what's going through your
mind
oh he's thinking he doesn't want the
money all right 40 seconds
all right take your time there we go
these are important jumps 10 grand on
the line
holy cow 70 seconds all right you have
30 seconds left oh you're clutching
you're clutching oh
no three come on go keep up
one no so close
you didn't win 10 grand but that's okay
because evan
just won ten thousand dollars evan
that must have been so hard for you oh
it's terrifying kick your head up pick
your head up
lock in are you subscribed to our
channel yes all of them then i'll give
you a consolation prize of a thousand
dollars
thank you so much hey i can't where are
you
all i see is trees this is what it
looked like at the start of the video
and here's what it looks like now ai cap
you planted
14 672
saplings holy crap oh my god
what the heck are you gonna do with all
this money i'm probably gonna give those
of it to my parents he blows a bit too
goodbye